INTRODUCTION: The
following content
is provided by MIT
OpenCourseWare under a Creative
Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I'll start now with
the third lecture.
And we're into partial
differential equations.
So we had two on ordinary
differential equations,
and the idea of stability came
up, and the order of accuracy
came up.
And those will be the
key questions today --
accuracy and stability.
We do get beyond that, actually.
I mean, to look at the contour,
at the output from a difference
method.
Once you've decided, yes, it's
stable, yes it's accurate,
you still have to
look at the output
and see, you know, how good
is it, where is it weak,
where is it on target.
But first come the accuracy
and stability questions.
And beginning with
this equation.
So this will be the
simplest initial value
problem we can think of.
I call it a one-way
wave equation.
Notice the two-way wave
equation, which we'll get too,
would have second
derivatives there.
And that will send waves
in both directions.
This, we'll see, sends a
wave only in one direction,
so it's a nice scalar problem.
First-order,
constant coefficient,
that's the velocity.
Perfect.
The model problem
for wave equations.
Because it's just
first order, I just
begin it with the
function at time 0.
So I'm looking for the solution
at time t to this equation.
OK.
So that will not
be hard to find.
And I want to do it first
for pure exponentials.
When u of x_0, the
initial function,
is a pure exponential
e to the i*k*x.
Because it really pays, to
-- Fourier is always around.
And to see what happens, suppose
this is given, for example --
so this will be my
example, e to the i*k*x.
OK.
Now what's special
about e to the i*k*x?
The special thing is that with
constant coefficients and no
boundaries, the solution will
be a multiple of e to the i*k*x.
In other words, we can
separate variables.
Maybe I'll put it here.
I can then look for the solution
u to be a function times --
a number really, but it
will depend on the time,
on the frequency k, and the
time t -- times e to the i*k*x.
You see how that
separated variables?
x is separated from t, and
the frequency controls what
this growth factor will be.
So this growth factors is
a key quantity to compute.
And we compute it
just by substituting
that hope for a solution
into the equation.
And getting an equation for
G, because e to the i*k*x will
cancel.
That's the key point,
that everything
remains a pure harmonic with
that single frequency k.
So if I plug it
in, I get dG/dt --
I'm taking the time derivative
of u -- times e to the i*k*x,
right?
That's du/dt.
Because t was separate
from x, that's what
I get when I plug in this u.
So I'm always
plugging in this u.
What do I get on the right-hand
side? c, the x derivative.
So that's just G. The x
derivative will bring down i*k,
e to the i*k*x.
No surprise that I can cancel e
to the i*k*x, which is never 0.
And I have a simple
equation for G. Linear,
constant coefficients,
but the coefficient
depends on k, of course.
The coefficient is i*c*k, and
of course the solution is G is
equal to -- we're back to our
simplest model of an ordinary
differential equation.
Now the coefficient
a is now i*k*c,
so it's e to the i*k*c*t, right?
That shows us what happens
to the e to the i*k*x.
So now I'll put that here,
because now we know it.
So we have altogether e to
the i*k*c*t, and here's an x.
So let's put those
together as x plus c*t,
because that's a guide
to what's coming.
So that's the solution:
separated variables, looked
for the growth factor,
tried an exponential.
And we'll do exactly the same
thing for difference method.
So this was von
Neumann's brilliant idea,
watch exponentials,
watch every frequency,
and see what happens to the
multiple of e to the i*k*x.
Now here is very special,
because all frequencies are
producing this
combination x plus c*t.
So when we combine frequencies
-- that's what Fourier said,
take combinations
of these things --
the solution will be a
combination of these things.
And what do we get?
If our original function
was u of x and 0,
it's a combination of
these, e to the i*k*x's.
And at later time, we
have the same combination,
by linearity of these guys.
All that's happening is x is
getting changed to x plus c*t.
So, I'm getting the answer.
Here was the answer
for one exponential.
But now I'm going to do
the answer for a general u,
and it's going to
be easy to pick off.
It's just like picking
off this x plus c*t.
It will be u at x
plus c*t at time 0.
That's the solution.
For every u, not just
for the exponentials,
but for all
combinations of them,
which give us any u of x and 0.
So u of x and 0 was
a combination of e
to the i*k*x's, and then
the solution is the same
combination of these guys.
Well, we can understand
what that solution is.
It's what I call a one-way wave.
Let me understand
what's happening here.
So here's the key picture now.
I want to a draw a
picture in the xt-plane.
So I'm not graphing u here.
This is a picture in the
xt-plane that will show us
what this formula means.
Because this is the
solution that we then
want to approximate
by difference method.
OK.
So what does this mean?
This means that the value,
for example, u of 0, 0 --
so there's the point (0, 0).
Here's what's happening, at
a later time, say up here,
some later time,
the value of u --
this is the line x
plus ct equals 0;
x plus ct equals
0 along that line.
And what's the point?
On that line, the solution is
the same all the way along.
So whatever the
initial value is here,
it travels, so that u at this
point is u at this point.
So let me to call that point
P, and say what I mean now.
I mean that u of P is
the same as u at 0, 0.
Because x plus c*t is
the same here and here.
Let me take another point, let's
say x_0, another initial value.
Then, again, along
the line like this --
this will be the line x
plus c*t equals capital X,
because it's the line where
x plus c*t is a constant,
and the constant is chosen so
that it starts at this point,
at t equals 0, X is big
X. So now -- let's see --
I better make clear -- that
this line carries this initial
value.
This line carries
this initial value.
You see it?
The value of u all
along this line
is the value it started
with right there.
And you know the
name for those lines?
So these are lines, they
happen to be straight here
because we got constant
coefficients, straight
and even parallel.
And they're the lines on
which the information travels.
Whatever the information
was at times 0.
By information, I
mean the value of u
at 0, 0, or the value
of u at this point.
That information
travels along that line
to give this solution
all along the line.
And the name of the
line, anybody know it?
Characteristic.
So this is a characteristic
line, they all are.
This too.
All these line are
characteristic lines.
Can you read characteristic?
I should of have written
it a little better.
So this is like a key
feature of wave equations.
It's a key feature
of wave equations
that we will not see
for heat equations.
And so let me just say it
again, because it will bear also
on the stability question
for difference equations.
The information, the
true information,
for the true solution, travels
along characteristic lines.
We're in one
dimension here, which
is a major simplification.
In two dimensions we'll
have characteristic cones.
In three dimension certainly
we'd call it a cone.
And actually, I
guess what I'm saying
is that if I speak
a word, you know,
my voice or the sound waves
solve the 3D wave equation.
So when I snap my
fingers, that sound
travels from this point
out along characteristics.
And of course it travels
in all directions,
so we've got a more interesting,
more complicated picture
in higher dimensions,
but we really
see it here in one dimension.
OK.
Now, I should also include
a graph of the solution.
What does the
solution look like?
Maybe I'll find a spot
here for that graph.
Now I'm going to graph u.
This is still x.
So I'll graph u at maybe
two different times.
So the starting time.
Suppose we have a wall of water.
So this will be u of x and 0,
a step function, maybe at 0.
So u of x and 0 is 1 and then 0.
OK.
So there's a typical
starting initial value.
Well, I don't know
if it's typical.
Pretty special to
have 1 and then 0,
a perfect step function.
But this will illustrate --
Now I want to ask, what's
the solution to the equation?
What is u of x and t?
I want to graph u of x and t.
What what happens?
You have to assemble, sort
of, this picture, which
is in the xt-plane, into a
graph here of u of x and t.
What happens?
Well all these zero
starting values travel along
characteristics, and tell
us that u is 0 along all
these characteristics.
So along all these
characteristics, u is 0.
This here, the
starting value is 1.
So along these characteristics
we're starting with a 1,
we end with a 1.
Do you see what happens?
How do I graph it?
The wave is moving.
The wall of water is moving
that way, moving to the left.
Because I'm taking c to
be a positive number.
So u of x and t is a wall,
or a wave you could say,
moving left with speed c.
Every solution to the
equation is doing this.
And in this particular
case it's a wall of water
and it stays a wall of water.
That the point.
Shapes are not changed as we go.
There's no -- dispersion would
be the right word, I think.
We would expect, in
a general equation,
that the shape of the wave would
change a little as it travels.
In this equation
it doesn't change.
The shape stays the same.
See, again I'm thinking of
this wave as a combination
of pure exponentials.
And they all travel
with the same speed c,
so the whole wave
travels with speed c.
And at a later time, that's
the graph of the solution.
OK.
So that much is all we have
to do, all we can do really,
in solving the
differential equations.
It's a simple model, certainly.
But now I come to the
difference equation.
Well, when I say the
difference equation,
I should say equations plural.
Because here I've written
four possibilities.
Three of them are actually
used, and one is a disaster.
But none of the four is perfect.
Most people would
say Lax-Wendroff
is the best of these
four, because it has
one extra order of accuracy.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I guess these all have
only first-order accuracy.
But Lax-Wendroff
moves up to second.
So that's a method
that everybody knows,
because it gets up to second.
But actually upwind is the
first one to start with.
Let me start with that one.
OK.
So I've multiplied up by
the delta t that should be
in the denominator there,
especially so that you would
see -- so upwind, or
forward difference --
I'm taking the standard
forward difference in time --
all these methods are
going to be explicit,
so they're all going to be
solvable in a simple way for u
at the new time.
So a forward difference
in time for du/dt,
and c times a forward
difference in space for du/dx.
So that's the first idea
that would occur to you,
and it's pretty reasonable.
We can check its accuracy, but
you can guess what it would be.
What's your guess on the
accuracy of this method?
You're seeing a
forward difference
in time, a forward
difference in space.
The odds are those finite
differences give you
an accuracy p -- if we use p
as the measure of accuracy --
which would be probably
1, first-order accurate.
So we'll see the accuracy
as only p equal to 1.
OK.
What about the stability?
I'm looking at
this first method.
So one comment
about the method is
that this ratio c
delta t over delta x,
let me call it r,
that's a key number.
it's called the
Courant number by some.
So in the literature you
might see the phrase Courant
number for that ratio r.
And maybe my first
point is, stability
is going to put a bound on r.
We can tell right away,
for this explicit method
and for any explicit method,
that r can't be unlimited.
There's going to be
a bound on r, which
it means a bound on delta t.
It's telling us that delta t has
to be less than some constant
times delta x.
And stability is the
job find that constant.
How small does
delta t have to be?
Now let me sort of understand
this forward difference method
in this picture.
So I'm going to do the forward
difference, delta t of u
equals that ratio times the
forward difference of the space
difference, so time differences
is that ratio times this space
difference.
OK.
Method 1.
So I guess somehow, you
want to see that the --
you want to see a picture
like this for the difference
equation, So the
difference equation,
we imagine we've got steps delta
x, all these steps are delta x.
Let's suppose that's 0.
OK.
So what happening now?
And time going this way and
I'm solving this equation.
What's happening here?
Let me copy this method,
u at a position j --
so this might be the
point j delta x --
at time n plus 1 is -- I want to
write this equation, as always,
in the most convenient way.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to take
this u of x and t
and put it on the
right-hand side.
So then my equation looks
like that ratio r times u
at j plus 1 at time n.
That's this.
I'm one position over,
but I'm at the given time.
And then what's the
coefficient of u_(j, n)?
So can you just tell me,
what do I put in there?
So this will be that nice
way to look at our difference
equation.
Each new value is a combination
of two old values, r
times the guy here.
So in other words, here's
my little molecule.
This is the new value.
It comes from r
times this plus what,
you have to tell
me what multiplies
this u at this point.
So here's u_(j, n+1), and here's
u_(j+1, n), and here is u_(j,
n).
And what goes in parentheses?
1 minus r.
Because I get the 1 when that
flips over to the other side.
Good.
So it's just a combination.
The new value is a
combination of those two.
And I guess what I want to show
is that it could not possibly
be stable unless r is
less or equal to 1.
So this will be the
Courant condition.
The condition on
the Courant number.
So the Courant
condition or the CFL --
that's a really a better
condition -- will be --
let me say what it is.
The CFL condition is
r less or equal to 1.
That's a condition for
stability or convergence
that comes to us from comparing
the real characteristics
with the finite
difference picture.
OK.
So what's CFL?
C is Courant still.
So this came from a
really early paper,
and I think actually Lewy.
That's Courant,
that's Friedrichs,
they were close friends.
That's Lewy, all three
were friends actually.
And I think it was actually
Lewy who spotted what we're just
going to do right now,
the requirement that r
had to be less or equal 1.
Now let me just make clear that
this Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition is going to be
a necessary condition.
It has to hold, or
there is no hope.
But it's not enough, it's
not a sufficient condition.
We can't guarantee that a method
stable just because the Courant
condition is satisfied.
The Courant condition
will tell us
something about the
position of characteristics,
we'll see it in a second.
For example, this centered
one is unstable, this guy,
when the right-hand
side -- you might say,
oh this is a better method;
always better to take
a centered difference for
du/dx than a one-sided.
But not now.
The one-sided one is OK.
The centered one is going
to be totally unstable,
for all r, this centered one.
And we'll identify that not
from Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy --
their paper wouldn't have
spotted the difference between
one and two, but
von Neumann did;
von Neumann quickly noticed that
if you use an exponential --
so we'll do one van
Neumann in a moment --
if you plug in an
exponential to number 2,
this centered
difference, it takes off.
And it's unstable even
if delta t is small.
OK.
Now what is this CFL,
Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition?
Where does that come from?
It comes from just thinking
about the information.
I have to write down
the thinking now
that goes into the
Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition, the CFL condition.
OK.
It's straightforward.
I have to think, at a time t,
let's say t equals n delta t.
Suppose I've taken
n times steps.
Then the true u at, let's
say, 0 and that time t is --
or x and t, because we
know the true solution.
The true u at x and
t is, as we know,
the initial function at
the point x plus c*t.
So that's the correct solution.
And Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
are just
saying that you better use this
number in finite difference
method or you don't
have a chance.
Right.
That makes sense.
So what do I mean
by use this number?
OK.
So let me draw.
So u at x and t is
some point here.
This is at the point x and t.
This used these two values.
They use these three values.
This one used that one,
that one, that one.
This one used those two.
Those four used
these five values.
Right.
See, the difference method is
not propagating the information
entirely on that line,
it's really taking values
over that whole interval
with some combinations of r
and 1 minus r.
And in the end, after
five times steps,
it's giving us this
value up there.
But the point is that if this
point x plus c*t were out here,
then refining delta x
and refining delta t,
and using more and more points,
and filling in and using more
of these, but not getting out
here, would get you nowhere.
You wouldn't have a chance.
So that's the
Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition.
How far out is this?
This is n delta x inside this.
And if this is x, this
is n delta x's away,
and this is x plus c*t.
And c is n delta t's.
Right?
t is n delta t.
Are you with me?
As I keep delta t over
delta x, the ratio r, fixed
and use more and more points,
I'm filling up this interval
with points that I've used.
But I'm never going to
get to a point there.
So the idea is then,
unstable, couldn't converge,
couldn't work, if the distance
reached here, n delta x,
is smaller than c*n delta
t, it couldn't work.
OK.
So I'm taking a negative
point of view here.
It can't work in this case.
The reason I take that
negative point of view is I'm
not able to say it does
work in the case when
delta x is big enough
compared to delta t,
and I include that point.
I can't be sure.
But I can be sure that
if I don't include
that neighborhood of where
the true u is produced,
it can't have a chance.
So let me just cancel
n, divide by delta x.
And I say fail if 1 is
smaller then c delta t
over delta x, which is r.
It fails if r is bigger
than 1, by this reasoning
of characteristics.
There are two more cases that
are worth thinking about.
Suppose the method was downwind.
So this is upwind, because
I take a forward difference.
The wind is blowing this way.
Forgive me for incomplete
use of the word wind.
I don't know what it means.
But one way or another,
whatever, the wind
is blowing this way.
The values are coming
from the upwind direction.
And that's good, because
the true value comes
from the upwind direction.
That's what we saw
in characteristics,
the values are blowing downwind.
So, what would happen if I use
a backward difference here?
So I didn't write that
bad idea, but it's
important to realizes that's
method 1a, a bad idea,
is to use a backward
difference here.
I should maybe call
it 1b, for backward.
You see that it would fail?
If I used a backward
difference, what will
what happen to this picture?
This value would come
from stuff on the left.
It would totally
have no chance to use
the correct initial value.
So a backward difference
is an immediate failure.
So r has to be -- It
will also fail if --
well I was going to
say r less than 0.
I don't know, can I say that?
The way r could be less than
0 would be the delta x being
negative, and that's what I
mean by the downwind method,
where I'm looking for
looking for the value here,
and of course I'm
not finding it.
OK.
So I guess I'm saying that
Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy tells
us right away that this method
will only have a chance --
it only has a chance if
r is -- so, possible,
and in fact this is the
stability condition.
So let me write that fact,
but we haven't proved it yet.
It's stable for r
between 0 and 1.
That's the stability condition,
which limits delta t.
Because r is delta
t over delta x.
And this says that
delta t can't be larger
than the multiple of delta x.
OK.
You might say, that sounds
like delta t is too small.
Is stability too restrictive?
Well it's restrictive certainly,
because it limits delta t.
But actually, for these methods,
accuracy also limits delta t.
If I look for an implicit
method, that would allow me --
if I looked for a method that
allowed a bigger delta t,
then the error of
that, in that method,
proportional to delta
t, would be too big.
In other words,
accuracy as well as
stability is keeping delta
t of the order of delta x.
Accuracy as well as stability
is keeping r within a bound,
and stability is keeping
it within those bounds.
OK.
So I still have to show
that the method is stable.
The Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition
just helps to eliminate
impossible ratios.
OK.
One more point, which of course
everybody notices, in solving
the difference equation.
Suppose r is exactly 1.
Think about the case
where r is exactly 1.
Remember that's c
delta t over delta x.
Suppose r is exactly 1, then
what does the method do?
The method takes the
new value, r is 1.
This is 0 now.
So the new value is then, when
r is 1, is that old value.
In this picture, when r is
1 this value is this one.
The values are
traveling along a line.
I'm not using these you see,
because if r is exactly 1,
these are exactly 0.
Now is that good?
Actually it's terrific,
because that line, when r is 1,
is the correct
characteristic line.
If r is 1, if c delta
t equals delta x,
I'm going up exactly with that
slope that the true line does.
In other words, the
difference equation
gives exactly the solution
to the differential equation.
Because it's so
simple of course.
Couldn't do it --
well, that's the point,
we can't do it for big problems,
because in a big problem c is
going to be variable.
Maybe the problem, c may depend
on the position or the time,
or it might depend
on the solution
u in a non-linear problem.
Those are ahead of us.
But this possibility in
1D -- it's only, really,
a one-dimensional possibility,
where the true information
travels on a line, and we could
just hope to stay close to that
characteristic line.
OK.
Now I'm ready to tackle,
for any method, the --
let me get these guys up again.
So first, I want to see,
why is upwind stable,
and why is centered unstable.
Should I start with the
stability question, rather than
the accuracy question?
The accuracy we could
guess was first order,
until we get to Lax-Wendroff.
So accuracy is going
to come next time.
We've had Courant's take on
stability, the CFL condition,
but now I'm ready for von
Neumann's deeper insight.
OK.
So how does von Neumann
study stability?
He watches every e to the i*k*x.
So von Neumann's test is going
to be each e to the i*k*x
should have a growth factor,
in the difference equation,
smaller then 1.
The growth factor in the
differential equation,
of course, was right on.
This has magnitude exactly 1.
So wave equations are not
giving us any space to work in.
Because we want -- the growth
factor and the difference
equation, we want it to
be close to the real one.
And at the same time, it
better be not -- the real one,
having absolute value
exactly 1 on the unit circle.
But the difference
equation is allowed
to go into the unit
circle, but not to go out.
OK.
That will separate the
good ones from the bad.
OK.
Let me work here on -- Can
I copy the equation u_(j,
n+1) is equal to r*u_(j+1,
n), and 1 minus r u_(j, n).
OK.
Now I'm going to do
an exponential again.
So I'm going to
have u, say, 0, n.
I'm going to start
from e to the i*k*x.
Sorry, let me say -- So, time
0 and position n will be e
to the i*k*n delta x.
Right.
That's my initial,
e to the i*k*x,
that's my pure frequency.
I plug that in to the
-- oh, not n but j;
j is measuring how many --
sorry, let's get it right --
j is measuring how many
delta x's I'm going across;
n is measuring how many
delta t's I'm going up.
So this is the key,
here's von Neumann.
Try a pure exponential,
plug it in.
Again, it's going
to work, because we
have constant coefficients.
So what do I get on
the right-hand side?
I get r times this
guy at level j plus 1,
e to the i*k j plus 1 delta
x times the exponential.
Can I save the
exponential, because it's
going to factor out?
Plus a 1 minus 4 times
the exponential itself,
and here's the exponential:
e to the i*k*j delta x.
This will be one step.
I could say u_(j, 1) coming
from level 0 to level 1.
Sorry, e to the i*k*j delta
x, so I don't need it here.
Sorry, I did it wrong.
That e to the i*k j plus 1 delta
x factors into e to the i*k
delta x from the 1, and
e to the i*k*j delta x,
which is over there.
So I only wanted this much.
OK.
Sorry, that's on the permanent
tape but maybe it's OK.
Because it makes
us think through,
what's the result from
a pure exponential?
And again, the result
is pure exponential
in, pure exponential
out, but multiplied
by some finite difference
growth factor G, that
depends on the frequency.
And it depends on delta
x and it depends on r.
Well actually it depends
on k delta x together.
So I could put that together.
What's von Neumann's
question now?
He wants to know is this number
-- it's a complex number,
of course, because it's got this
cosine of k delta x plus i sine
of k delta x -- he wants
to know is it -- magnitude,
does the magnitude
get bigger than 1?
If so, n steps will give
the n-th power of the thing,
and it will blow up.
Or does the
magnitude stay lesser
equal to 1, in which case it
won't blow up, in which case
we have stability.
Of course, it would be great
if the magnitude was always
exactly 1.
Because that's what
the true solution has.
But that's only going to happen
in this special, special case
when r equals 1, and
I'm going just right
on the characteristic.
When r is exactly 1, that's
the case when that's gone,
this is a 1, and that
has magnitude exactly 1.
But normally, r is
going to be, I'm
going to be on the safe
side, r will be less than 1.
And I just want to draw this von
Neumann amplification factor.
I'll often use the
word growth factor,
just because it's
shorter, but another word
is amplification factor.
What does an exponential
get amplified by?
Can you identify this
number in the complex plane?
Of course, the big
question is, where is it
with respect to the unit circle?
OK.
Take k equals 0 -- zero
frequency, the DC term,
the constant start -- what is
that number equal when k is 0?
1.
So that's normal.
At k equals 0, we're
right at the position 1.
That's just telling us that
a constant initial value
stays unchanged.
The true growth factor and
the von Neumann amplification
factor both 1.
But now let k be non-zero.
Where is this complex number?
And now, I'm going to
impose the condition
that r is between 0 and 1,
because I know from Courant
that is going to be required.
What's the point here?
OK.
Then, you see, here
is a 1 minus r.
So there's 1, 1 minus r will
be a little bit in here,
and then what happens
when I add on this number?
So the 1 minus r I've done.
It put me here.
It was real.
But this number is not real.
This number is r times
some complex number,
but what do I know?
I do something critical here.
What do I know
about this number?
I know its absolute value is 1.
So that it gets
multiplied by an r.
Look, look, look, look.
I start with a 1 minus r.
So I go to 1, back
to r, and now I
add in this part, which is
somewhere on a circle of radius
r that's everything
in this problem.
It's a circle of radius r
around the point 1 minus r.
I'm inside the circle,
and you could say, well,
you could have seen that clearly
by just using the triangle
inequality.
The magnitude of this can't
be bigger than the magnitude
of that, which is what?
r.
Plus the magnitude of
that, which is what?
1 minus r.
So the magnitude, by
the triangle inequality,
can't be more than r plus
1 minus r which is 1.
But now wait a minute, where
did I use the Courant condition?
The way I said
that there sounded
like it would always work.
This has magnitude r.
What's going on here?
Suppose r is bigger than
1, what's going wrong?
In fact, what's the picture
if r is bigger than 1?
If r is bigger than 1, then my
1 minus r is out here somewhere.
So this is the unstable
case, 1 minus r,
and then a circle of
radius r, bad news, right?
Every frequency is
unstable in fact.
When I'm reaching too far,
and that's just telling me
I'm not using the
information I need.
I don't have a chance
of keeping, controlling
any frequency.
OK.
I've got just
enough time to show
how bad this second method is.
So nobody wanted
his name associated
with that second method.
Why is that?
So what's the von Neumann
quantity for the second method?
OK.
Just space here to write
-- so this is now --
I want to know the number
for that second method.
So now the method is
u_(j, n+1) is u_(j, n),
from the time difference,
plus r over 2, u_(j+1,
n) minus u_(j-1, n).
This is going to
be the bad method.
It looks good because
the centered difference
is more accurate than
a one-sided difference,
but it's also unstable here.
Can you look at that and see
what the von Neumann number
G is going to be?
Think of an
exponential going in.
What exponential comes out?
So G is a 1 from this.
Now this is our guys
that's shifted over,
so that would be in r over
2 e to the i*k delta x,
just as it was before.
And this one will be a minus
r over 2 times e to the --
so it's back one step, so there
will be an e to the minus i*k
delta x.
So what's with this now?
G is 1 plus this quantity, r
over 2 times e to the i*k*x
minus e to the minus i*k*x.
What am I seeing there?
I'm seeing 1 plus r, and
everybody recognizes this minus
this over 2 as i sine,
i*r sine k delta x.
That's the amplification factor,
and is it smaller than 1?
No way.
Let me raise it up here.
So I don't care whether r is
less than 1 or not, I'm lost.
This is a pure imaginary number.
This is a real number.
So I have the sum of squares
to get the magnitude,
it will be the square root of 1
plus r sine k delta x squared.
So if I draw the bad picture
then, what's the bad picture?
Is now, it goes to 1 and then it
goes way up the imaginary axis.
Well maybe not way up, but up.
Sorry, I shouldn't have made
it quite as bad as it was.
If I reduce r, I don't go
so far up, but no hope.
So do you see why
that one is bad,
because the
amplification factor --
von Neumann tells us what
Courant did not tell us,
that the amplification factor
here has magnitude bigger than
1.
It's outside the circle, and
every exponential is growing
and there's no hope.
OK.
So the second last lecture on
this section 5-2 of the notes
will be about Lax-Friedrichs
and Lax-Wendroff,
order of accuracy, stability
and actual behavior in practice.
OK.
See you Wednesday.
Thanks.